la peor cifra en cuatro décadas según el
banco mundial la pandemia contrajo la
economía costarricense en un 41 por
ciento en 2020 después de un período de
25 años de crecimiento constante siendo
estos los principales desafíos para la
nación centroamericana que se acercará a
las urnas este domingo 6 de febrero en
busca de un nuevo presidente el
candidato que ya gobernó entre 1994 y
mañana 298 duelos más opcionales acceder
al cargo según las encuestas propone
alternativas
por supuesto que nos vamos a acercar a
todas las organizaciones financieras
internacionales para ver en qué podemos
mejorar los acuerdos que se hayan dejado
por esta administración otra
preocupación de los 3 millones y medio
de votantes registrados es el desempleo
todo un porcentaje del 14,4 por ciento
es el más alto de la década algunos
culpan a la gestión del mandatario
saliente carlos alvarado y a las dos
tendencias políticas tradicionales
unidad social cristiana y el partido de
la liberación nacional del que el iner
saborío forma parte
cuatro años no son suficientes para
solventar
todo lo que no se hizo o cosas que se
hizo mal pero si nos da la posibilidad
de parar la situación de recomponernos
en todo cuanto se puede pero además
avanzar el resultado de la votación del
domingo para los 57 diputados de la
asamblea unicameral del país también es
incierto con todos los escaños en
disputa está pendiente la legislación
relacionada al cumplimiento de los
términos con el fondo monetario
internacional que le proporcionará al
país 1800 millones de dólares para
solventar la crisis una situación que
aprovecha el tercer candidato favorito
fabricio ha ganado nosotros queremos
renegociar conversar ya lo estamos
haciendo con el fondo para que cuando
seamos gobierno ellos sepan que nuestra
ruta si es sanear las finanzas pero no
golpeando el bolsillo de los
costarricenses según las últimas
encuestas ningún candidato alcanzará el
40 por ciento de los votos necesarios
para ganar una primera vuelta el
resultado podría definirse el 3 de abril
con un balotaje